new in theaters this weekend the good
liar Ford versus Ferrari and Charlie's
Angels what will you see this is your
weekend ticket
[Music]
how much do dishes worth nearly 3
million take it off
do you know who you are you're the only
person on this planet who makes me feel
that I'm not alone based on the novel of
the same name the good liar tells the
story of a con artist who targets a
well-off Widow and hopes of swindling
her fortune but before he knows it he
starts catching feels for her and also
might have to face his criminal past
this movie is for you if a suspense
movie sounds good to you this weekend
you're a fan of the stellar acting of
being McKellen and Helen Mirren or
you're a widow with a large fortune
looking for your soul mate who also
happens to be a host hi I will put you
in the driver's seat with Lamar just
shut your mouth and let me do my thing
morning Shelby laurenmolly populace now
go to hell when a deal for the car
company Ford to buy Ferrari falls
through after Ferrari declines to
surrender their racing division ford
spitefully sets to beating the nearly
undefeated Ferrari by hiring a dream
team duo to help them construct a car
that can win the 24-hour limo through
much trial and error the team sets to
conceiving and constructing a car they
think can win the Ford gt40 this movie
is for you if an action drama sounds
like a fun ride this weekend you're
excited to see Matt Damon and Christian
Bale together or if you're a car sorry
there's more there if you're a car fan
you may not know we exist but we are
always watching
[Music]
you are in the presence of angels things
are going pretty great for the Townsend
agencies angel program as they've
expanded internationally and now run
several groups of angels all over the
globe as a newcomer is trained to join
their ranks they're enlisted to stop a
dangerous technology that threatens the
world the movie is written produced
directed and also features Elizabeth
Banks who has done the same for the
pitch-perfect series so if you like
those you'll probably like this this
movie is for you if a fun action movie
calls to you this weekend
you want to see these three ladies kick
some butt or you're still trying to
figure out if you can call them angels
cuz the song keeps saying don't call
them angels but they're angels like what
that is your weekend ticket what will
you see and check back next week for
frozen - a beautiful day in the
neighborhood and 21 bridges